[Music]
who is it scream is the word who is it
facts tell the truth what you doing to
us don't leave us on a [__] don't
dangle the car like that first of all
we're a team you can never break us up
you can never break us up second of all
who is
[Music]
it right guys we're back with another
Banger and as per usual we go straight
into it we don't really like foreplay we
just we just go straight in
dog cuz we're selfish lovers we're
selfish menaces that's exactly what we
are the question of the week this week
was what's the most unorthodox way
someone has called you ugly and yeah the
streets the streets came through I bet
the streets came through I remember when
my ex used to call me a frog do you
remember I do that hurt my feelings it
hurt
mine it hurt mine because she said it to
your face and I was like I remember I I
remember F like the 5th of November I
remember it was like that I can't
believe it yeah wow yeah that was that
was so painful wow yeah it was it was
damn she was hurt yeah she really was H
it was a bit of comment you're not about
us at all bro it's a bit of com bro all
right the most unorthodox way someone
has called you ugly I asked them out on
a date they responded with um that was
14 weeks
ago text um just that that's it 14 weeks
ago you shouldn't Veer out of your
lane I sometimes want to send that to
people that DM me you shouldn't Veer out
your lane put that lane control on yeah
put that lane control on yeah
wow to some people that DM me I re I do
realize though like someone was speaking
to me about this the other day and they
were like where did they get the nerve
yeah the G the bra the GH the Bravada
the audacity the confidence but is a
case of like when you see someone as not
a real person per se it gives a
confidence of like what's the worst
that's going to happen here facts he's
never going to read it he's never going
to read it and if he does if he says yes
then wow gang imagine um but yeah that's
when I don't rate the only ones I don't
rate is when they give the full full
breakdown oh God yeah bre let's go out's
have some CH I'm a good like this is
never going to happen why
you if you're just a quick you're
banging let's do something um or you're
banging let's go out or whatever it's a
case of yeah you probably think I'm
never ever going to read it see it reply
whatever and the top side is It's
banging and the bottom side is I just
carry on my day cuz once you press sent
it's done but when it's paragraphs I'm
like what what reality you living what
are you expecting from this a
should bear out of your lane crazy I
that's such a horrible thing to hear
it's a statement it's a statement right
continuing most unorthodox way someone's
called you
BS you were curing for intelligence
whilst they were giving away
Beauty oh my
God oh my God oh my
god wow yeah bro queing for intelligence
whilst they were giving away beauty is
crazy that's nuts crazy crazy yeah wow
that's um that takes some yeah that took
four yeah yeah yeah yeah wow Jesus I was
standing with my friend and a guy came
up to us and said one of you girls are
pretty and just
left fight out facts fight out the
winner shout
me how darant would it be if you assumed
you were the ugly one as well one of you
is pretty and just walked off and then
you just like you just we both look at
each other yeah so just go talk to her
it's not me so just talk to her I
haven't got time for this bro I'm not
going to be oh is she talking to me no
yeah how would you feel if if a chick
said that to us one of you Butters no
one of you and just walks off one of you
[__] sexy sexy G I tell us then yeah
I I know for a fact both of us would as
she walks between us we both turn around
and scream at her who is it scream is
the word who is it [__] what you doing
truth what you doing to us don't leave
us on a the car like that first of all
we're a team you can never break us up
you can never break us up second of all
who is
it that's jokes that's hilarious right
next raw pepperoni pizza due to my
acne you got called a pepperoni pizza
pepperoni pizza that's fight talk
bro as an
outsider
go as an outsider what are your views on
pretty privilege
[Laughter]
no that's Su
Outsider because you know when you're
receiving that it's not on a a back and
forth you've approached me while I'm
eating
lunch my business I got my glasses on
and I got my tuna sandwich in Hand by
myself minding my business headphones in
business and you're just like question
as an outsider and I'm Peak my
interest yeah what are your views on
pretty
privilege I launched my T to some's face
yeah bro the [__] that's that's brazy
all right someone said I look like God
made me with my left with his left hand
Peak that's a piss take
Peak a friend posted a bikini pck and
someone commented so brave can't wait to
see that
after nah that's not possible so
brave wow that's not possible can't wait
to see the AR oh nah that's not possible
the so brave wood yeah yeah yeah would
make me delete the whole post R you have
to delete the post cuz that that comment
has 177,000 likes and all the comments
are how dare you how dare you how dare
you you pig and it doesn't make the
person feeling it really really does all
the comments are like she's gorgeous
inside and out so [__] you oh my phone
will be pinging oh God my phone be ping
so brave that so brave is dangerous
right instead of a sight for sore eyes I
was a sore sight for many eyes damn [__]
who's hearing this like apart from the
Frog thing no one's ever cast me that to
my face yeah fact bro that takes courage
and also like you are also not a person
that cares about
retaliation because you can't just say
that to a random human being and not
expect anything to happen I remember one
time I was chatting to my um
firsh girlfriend okay and I was at 18
mhm when we was in that talking stage
yeah I can't remember what I said but
she said I think you're nice looking by
only date Hench
guys cool cool yeah that will let me go
to gym straight away fad straight away
fuad straight away I used my youth
membership at the local Council run gym
yeah and I was pressing aut the weights
my God I had the TW in my hand shaking I
only date Hench I only date Hench guys I
think you're good looking about only day
Hench guys laughing face laughing face
laughing face oh it wasn't face to face
no it was on like MSN or something or
Myspace or laughing face laughing face
yeah only day Hench guys ha nah nah see
the thing is like
women will say the most cred to a guy
about his appearance or whatever and
like you said laugh about it and just
expect us to carry on with our life oh
because the thing is what's what's mad
is that she's saying laughing laugh
laughing laughing laughing only joking I
will date you yeah but it's only so
funny because you know it's facts facts
the you're still calling me Marga you're
still calling me Marga facts Jokes Aside
yeah yeah facts the damage has been done
oh and it was done cuz I still remember
it on out oh God sorry I remember
telling my Breen he he was Gob
smacked and then my brethren went to
college with her ex yeah and he was like
her ex is wh actually her her ex
actually is
wham well she's pissed Now isn't it cuz
I'm huge so haha she's pissed now right
uh most most unorthodox way you've been
called ugly every friendship group has a
dog [__]
you every
friend n a dog oh yeah yeah n no no no
no no no no no n n no no no we're not
doing that I'm sorry our family take our
bloodline very
seriously oh speaking of I was in First
Dates last
night wow yeah
wow tangent yeah yeah yeah let me get
back to First Dates all right co co I
don't want to slag them off I stayed at
a um a hotel in shortage last
night um actually let me not even Bait
it cuz that's that's actually out of
order what the the hotel yeah okay if
you know who you are sort your TVs out
okay 100 year old TVs up in that [__]
Hotel ain't cheap okay 100 year old TVs
I was living connection was whack oh God
not even smart TVs bro really not even
smart TVs did I have a TV did I have did
I have a back off or was it flat screen
it was flat screen okay but it might as
well not have been oh God the connection
was trash damn anyway I was watching
First Dates last night yeah you love a
bit of like trash TV when I'm in a hotel
F had yeah Kitchen Nightmares First
Dates naked traction four in a bed four
in a bed [__] off four in a bed come D
with me my days in a Telly when I'm
scaming my breakfast are you out of your
mind oh man my fire stick's in bro I'm
on streaming services I ain't got time
for terrestrial no because I don't want
the like I don't know what it is it's
like it's only when I know I'm trying to
sleep or when I'm just chilling because
when I if it's a fire sting or a laptop
open I don't want to leave where I'm at
so like this morning for example I knew
I had to come here so [__] TV is
perfect for me absolutely perfect for me
if I'm cracking open the laptop you know
I'm going to be late you know I'm going
to be late don't let me sck my teeth in
fair fair fair fair fair um anyway yeah
back to what you're saying old TV old TV
watching First Dates last night mhm and
some guy there was one Nigerian Dawn on
there disabled oh he had one arm missing
and one
arm like half an arm and the hand was
massive oh okay and then the date he was
on was like oh have you ever had a
girlfriend mhm or how no how long was
your last relationship mhm he said it
was 3 years long mhm do you know how he
said it ended he said it was when he was
living in
Nigeria home girl rocked up to his
yard and
um gave him a wedding
invitation wow he said they were calm
bopped to his yard just giving an
invitation to her wedding
in wow and said that was it and he said
these Nigerian families don't play with
disability wow she said we were kushy
for for three years wow but they don't
play with disability they said you're
not giving that to my use and that's on
God so she's getting married and it
ain't going to be to you yeah it was
crazy oh my it was
crazy wow wow indeed just locking years
years come on man wi an invitation why
you inviting me come on bro why you
inviting me facts facts why you doing
that to me bro just dump me in the first
six months if if you're thinking about
it that dump me 100 don't Che you know
your dad's not going to have it don't
play with me like this or tell me tell
me you're down but it will come to an
end I will lap up the six seven eight
months it'll be the best yeah it will it
really really what else with what I can
do it will be the best yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah God that's that's
uncom yeah my jaw hit a floor when I
watched that last night Jesus yeah
wedding invitation wedding invitation a
man said it on national TV I wouldn't
tell anyone I'd fakes I'd lie bro I'd
lie he he he had nothing enough to lose
I'm not going to lie to you fair play
fair play right I'm just going to Breeze
through these last ones here um most
most unorthodox way someone called you p
a girl in school said she'd seen dropped
kebabs prettier than me oh [__] you
that's
a girl said that in school dropped
kebabs this dude they splatter as well I
was going to say they look like sick on
the floor yeah they splatter that garlic
May is all over the
place oh my God this dude called me and
my best friend Fat fatherless horse
after she broke up with
him fat fatherless horse fatherless
that's unnecessary that's unnecessary
it's not my fault and it's got [__] do
my
[Music]
weight it was that alliteration got
nothing to do with my BMI he left cuz
he's a piece of [__] facts fatherless
bro both of them oh my
god oh treacherous oh God Blocked me as
soon as I sent a snap of myself humbled
me
differently peak one of my um Peak sorry
I'll let you no no one of my boys told
me recently
yeah one of my boys told me recently he
got catfished you got catfished he he
got catfish he told me he got catfished
on like hinge or some [__] okay said she
was buff and then bucked her in person
mhm um and she was not paying oh God not
paying oh God and he said he was
entirely gentlemanly entirely
gentlemanly like he continued the date
he continued the date he said basically
they went for a walk around a lake they
just met up uh to go for a walk okay
when he met her he s saw it charged it
saw it on the spot yeah charged it yeah
and was like let's just do this walk and
he said he was hot stepping around this
Lake let's get this over with but he
said he was entirely gentleman he said
like I did not want to let her know that
I thought she was a catfish whatsoever
after the date she clearly knew she was
a catfish so much that straight after
the date she
said um
ah was everything all right and face to
face or no no she text him okay it was
everything all right he said yeah it's
fantastic like what's up she said I just
felt like um you were a bit off do I
disgust
you don't ask me something I'll tell you
the truth I'll tell you the truth I
don't know you I don't owe you anything
thing I'll tell you the
truth family did I disgust you wow she
knew she knew who says that about
themselves she knew bro who literally
says that after mean someone one time
did I disgust you damn the selfefficacy
is low hella low why you going on the
date facts change up the whole profile
let them love you for you facts oh wow
it was crazy damn damn he saw her and
charged it charged
K even charged it God all right cool
last view my sister commented okay twin
on a female influencer selfie and she
got
blocked how dare you how dare you see
how dare you associate me with you yeah
and see with that I look like you twin
blocked oh wow okay damn fam the last
time I saw something like you I flushed
it
no
no no bro FL
it [__] you literally say I'm a piece of
[__] literally bro
literally
B that's actually like a hot 16 it is it
is it's to wrap this [__] up Jesus
Christ oh my
God
all right a two bagger the definition a
chick so ugly you put a bag over your
head just in case her one falls
off you got called a two bagger a two
bagger yeah wow
bro last two we can meet after
Sunset and last one the school bully
said I was so dark that I sweat crude
oil
[Laughter]
no nah bro crude oil nah the school
bullies [__] off the public the public
are funny man yeah they're out of order
man speaking of you know when I
mentioned my boy a minute ago yeah yeah
I was thinking about something the other
day that popped into my head and I
wasn't going to bring it up cuz I never
have did I never tell you man that I got
catfish one time no
considering you you wait when you say
you got catfish like you went out and
she was buts or someone used your
profile no no no no no no no no I was
chatting to a thing who catfished me but
I never actually lucky hands up I never
actually met her okay talk to me but I
nearly risked it all you man and you man
never knew about it and you were you
were present so okay I this is so dumb
when I basically I got DMD by a chick
it's a similar story to one you've told
before okay I got dm' by a chick on
IG years ago I'm talking like second or
third year of uni okay he lived in Manny
okay she lived in
Manchester baddy some blunting
completely out of my league but I didn't
C wasn't even a word back then mhm mhm
completely out of my league I was just
chatting the most okay Co incidentally
that weekend we were going out in
Liverpool okay a quick hop hop skip jump
yeah yeah say brother so we took the
national Express up to Liverpool did as
we do did our thing on the way back we
were stopping at Manchester no change
overs no nothing the the coach was just
stopping at
Manchester and then going taking us home
MH brother I didn't tell you man we
pulled up at Manchester and as we were
there I was messaging cuz basically she
was saying oh on your way home stop and
stay with me for a couple days and I was
like couple days fam and she was but
when I say she was talking crud okay I
was like it's going to be a couple days
yeah yeah I'm going to need yeah to do
what I need to do to you it's going to
be a couple days yeah I need that RNR
after yeah she was like I've got my own
yard's pattern she's like I can't wait
and I was like stuff like that yeah
couple days a couple days I was likeo
what's
I kept it stor yeah yeah okay okay okay
smart move
fam when we landed in Manchester when I
say I grabbed my hold door you man was
sitting I walked to the front of the bus
and I was just about to tell you man
like Deuces Deuces I'm going go link
thing just so you man thought I had
Mystique
yeah cuz I want you man to ask questions
yeah yeah yeah don't worry about that
you want to get back about L I wanted
you man to think I was cool so I'm
messaging her as we're pulling up to
Manchester like yeah I'm here I'm
here left on red left on red left on red
and I was like what's going on babe walk
on B yeah what's the address yeah what's
going on when I said I had like £25 in
my account at this point so I was like
if this doesn't pattern I'm [__] I
can't even get the next coach home yeah
yeah yeah I'm like babe babe babe babe
babe bab babe bab bab bab babe babe Ed
Red Ed Red Ed Red Ed when I said I had
one foot out the bus you man were we
asleep or I don't know what was
happening remember but I had one for and
I literally had to hesy yeah come back
sit down and just shut my mouth
nervous dis sheveled and nervous
thinking I near rised it all and I
remember thinking when the bus uh when
Donnie turned the engine back on I was
thinking please reply please reply it's
not too late it's not too late
run I need to get off it's not too
late bro I stayed on the thing
refreshing it for like 10 15 minutes a
it she texted me the next day
sorry missed this what the [__] ever bro
and for I said cfish wasn't a word yeah
but yeah that's what happened damn
million per damn and it's dread as well
cuz if you actually saw this man's
profile it's this chick's profile you
would know 1 million per was catfish
cish it was like two photos on there
they they were taking on a calculator oh
but at the time you didn't at the time I
just thought she just hasn't got the
aesthetic yeah she's banging regardless
say less that's a shame yeah it was bars
anyway anyway welcome back guys indeed
um episode 321 I believe of the [__] and
gigs podcast second best podcast
globally
globally um we actually are Spotify
check out we actually are
s as's a category if you go into the
hidden documents on Spotify head into
like yeah head into the green screens
facts the BIOS get in there and it just
says second best is shis and gigs gigs
first na that's what it says facts non
applicable second [__] and gigs anyway
guys head on over to patreon.com for/
[__] and gigs contribute three pound a
month 10p a day make yourself a top boy
or a top girl because if you're not a
top boy what are you bottom boy come on
we don't do bottom boys over here we're
top boys only facts so binge over four
years worth of content now juicy juicy
juicy juicy indoctrinate yourselves into
this cult make yourself a forever person
yes sir live vicariously through us your
daddies you know you want to anyway d
you're going to contribute to money and
you're going to live vicariously as we
spend your riches just like cult daddies
do facts bro if you're watching on
YouTube please subscribe to the channel
if you are listening on any of the audio
platforms please leave us a nice review
without any further Ado we
have top five top five top five I know
you guys have missed it but be back
let's go remind us of the scores please
Ellis sir yeah let me pull it up score
is
1383 138
three Ellis man [__] fre man new game
please right so this top five is again
one a different type of top five it's
not a top five it's just called top five
all right we are doing something we've
done before and it is guess the height
guess the height yes mhm all right okay
so I'm going give you a couple actresses
all you have to do is guess the hype my
Bros yeah yeah okay and that's it for
today right you ready we got our pens
um cool the first person reys with a
spoon Rees with a spoon H is like who
the [__] that I know the name I'm
trying to think of the person withon
Legally Blonde what else is she in she's
currently in the morning with um oh with
Jenn
Jen oh I know who she's in friends she
was in friends she
sister is she DN that's the only that's
the only thing I from yeah Ross was lost
inner yeah lost inner yeah I remember
lost inner sh the
curtains forgot um cool everyone written
there down mhm yeah cool
next let's go Sandra Bullock you all
locked yep third one Cameron
Diaz it's the fancy Cameron D there's U
was it night and day with um Tom
Cruz which one was that night movie
called night and day like night like a
night like a fight and night not like
night but and I'm sure she's in that I
can't even remember yeah I'm sure she
was banging in that and there was
another one she was in with is it Justin
timlake when she was like a teacher bad
teacher teacher Bad Teacher yeah Bad
Teacher I never forget bro one of the
opening scenes she has sex appe she has
a she's a gold digger isn't it I can't
remember she's a gold she's married to
one rich guy and she comes in and she's
like um um something like get them
drawers off I'm about suck that dick
like I'm mad at
it she said what bro I was in Bad
Teacher but it's early on never forgot
it take them drawers off I would have
suck that dick like I'm mad at
it Cameron Diaz wow yeah yeah never
never never h at the Moon that day I H
at the [__] Moon that day wow yeah
say less yeah right we all locked with
Cameron Diaz's height yeah cool and
number four Nicole
Kidman [__] camera is banging I watched
The Mask like last year I haven't seen
that in ages she's
unbelievable in that
movie all right last but not least um
let's
do Natalie
Portman if there are any like tie breaks
I've got more Heights so we can run it
from there okay cool everyone's locked y
yeah of course Ellis um Ellis let's go
with you first
cool so first one 5' four so did you
write the names or you just wrot
the Reese with a spoon yep 54 you got 54
show was quite small okay how may we
going to write this down all right
54 yeah next one was Sandra Bullock 5'8
yeah next one was Cameron
Diaz I about 510 I think that's a bit
too tall she looks
tall next one was Nicole
Kidman I B 55 I have no idea who that is
you know Nicole Kidman's Fair Play She's
old to be fair and Natalie Portman uh
about
5'9 cool she look a bit uh
REM um I went oh [__] 55
yeah yeah 57 yeah
yeah
58 y
5'4 yeah 57
57 cool Jimmy r with is been 5'2 yeah
Sandra b 5'8 yeah Cameron Diaz 5'9 yep
Nicole Kidman 55 yeah Natalie Portman 52
cool answers are Reese with a spoon is
actually 5'1 damn it Jesus so
none Sandra bulock is actually 5'7 so
REM you got that right [__] Cameron Diaz
is actually 5 foot n gang Jimmy got that
one REM you were off by you were both
off by one you went 5'8 you went 510
I've been off by one on all of them
apart from that true um Nicole Kidman
none of you got right she's tall she's
5'11 damn yeah last but not least
Natalie Portman is 53 [__] Jimmy R 52 H
REM 57 ell R 5'9 so Jimmy you've got one
rem's got one ell's got none so it's
tiebreaker time all right let's go wipe
your boards and go again Well Ellis you
can put your board back sorry sir yeah
might as well put it in the [__]
bin it's actually not your fault bro oh
height is it's R that's anyone's game
yeah height is random as hell charg it
these ones are charged from the get go
doesn't matter I've got no ego about
these these games all right cool
Charlie the Ron
o
locked locked cool you locked first tell
me the height 510 you locked second
obviously 59 [__] hell 510 gang come
on man so
boring what's that
1483 ell said I don't care
whatever
gang lovely hope you you guys got some
answers right right guys time for a
quick break yes sir because today we are
bought to you by who you guessed it
manscaped you say bought or
brought I said brought you said bought
bro I don't know what I said I said
bought I meant
BR anyway guys ignore fears rud
Interruption we are brought to you today
by manscaped who has taken a step up
from ballen to bring your f the cleanest
shave has ever seen this Eason no need
to toil in trouble manscapes all new
handyman is the best way to get rid of
all that stubble guys I have a personal
endorsement it's hard I actually used it
the other day gang it's hard did you get
yours uh not yet no you didn't get it
actually what wasn't it maybe I did get
it it's a box it's got the handyman in
it and mine had two pairs of boxes is
the thing with the the phone the yeah
the scrubby scub
put that straight in the bathroom
straight inom I got I got I got it right
featuring a compact design and NextGen
skin safe technology the handy man was
decided to give you that smooth finish
without the mess of a traditional shave
get the sweetest treat this Halloween by
going to manscape.com and use the code
sng Sierra November gold for 20% off
plus free shipping let's get back to the
episode SK right so you've got a little
something to sell us
apparently uh ask us what to say yeah
bro go on bro go on
bro you man I watched the first maybe
five episodes of Castlevania a yes you
man yes bro you man pull it up real
quick please I need to get the
character's names again um nocturn is it
no yeah nocturn oh my goodness oh yeah
these men are on stuff bro the um oh not
the go to like the obviously always cast
but like characters characters rather
yeah that's the
one that's the one yeah zoom in for me
please my eyesight a where it used to be
I never got their pictures to BS but
anyway
um es or Elizabeth baffy whatever her
name is the actual main
Vamps woo she's hard
she's hard bro I've not seen a like that
in a minute next level in a
minute remember when I say she enjoys
killing people it's crazy she physically
you seen the whole thing right I've seen
the whole thing the scene where all of
them
are um trying to spy on um they're
trying to spy on the guy that killed um
those those two new characters that came
in the black girl and the other guy and
like this the the vampires are like
dying in or whatever and one person
clocks them and they all clock them
scariest moment and they start stepping
back yeah yeah scariest moment and they
start running and their face changed I'm
like oh my God oh my God oh my God how
are they getting out of this how are
they getting out of this terrifying bro
there's so many scenes that are [__]
terrifying in that and it doesn't make
sense bro bro is so far I think it
actually might be my favorite it's my
favorite carvia it's 100% my favorite
carvia wow it's good you don't need to
watch Castlevania pre to understand this
they're two different stories and it's
it's just the reason why I love this is
because this is like a true definition
of cut the fat give me the arms
house cut all that fat give me the arms
house and one thing I do love about it
um as well is this is random this this
is a tangent I'll get back to it in a
second every time I watch shows series
movies or whatever I've always had this
um thought if I ever created a show
I would I would never ever ever ever
waste time with opening credits I would
just the way I view it in my head is I
would um get the cameraman to do like a
wide shot long angle type of thing and
have like a massive sign for example
breaking badges pop up that's it I want
to waste [__] time in credits show me
the Juicy Juice cut the fat I got time
for opening credits that's what cvia did
just put carvia knockturn director
written let's get let's get to the the
real [__] yeah bro oh bro it's it's it's
[__] fantastic and I've I think I've
got like three apps to watch yeah it's
absolutely fantastic the backstory of
Annette Annette is the black chick that
can control um slavery yeah they can
control oh my god when I say they
grabbed her mom and snapped her neck
just like that bro yeah it was crazy
like that nut oh bro her back story is
crazy her back story is her master as
well villain he is a villain
he is a big villain yeah yeah yeah bro
ah it's it's it's so good it's next it's
actually so good um have you seen you
may not have seen you you probably
haven't seen it rictor's op moment yet
no [__] because I doubt I probably doubt
it because um you [__] know about it
if you had I'm assuming I'd like to
believe he uses magic in this in yeah so
I've not seen it I've not I've not seen
it because obviously I I forgot he could
use Magic obviously from when cuz he did
that little [__] PE thing everybody
going die no no you're [__] bro but
then he start using the Whip and blah BL
I forgot he could do magic yeah cuz he
um in the story he can't do it anymore
he says he can't do can't do it anymore
yeah fam yeah fam oh say less when
shit's on the line oh my God oh my God
say less bro yeah yeah yeah it's nuts
yeah oh they Edward when they were
running off the island they drapes him
yeah they draped him be they Jaws on his
bear Jaws on his neck the one thing I I
liked about this you know in like shows
and series especially on Netflix it will
show you the category 18 plus whatever
and it will show you a quick description
the genre it says injury detail AKA arms
house bro AKA arms house and blood bro
when um the hanging bodies thing that
you talk me about cuz you you me did you
mention it in the last episode when they
were hanging bodies
I think it's like episode two or episode
three um
she's I think is when is this when
Anette no anette's not trying to escape
it is um it's uh I can't remember her
name she's one of the it's a shame
they've not got a [__] pictures there
it's pissing me off um one of the chicks
I think she's got blonde hair she was
trying to save her
sister
H yeah yes bro that's there yeah fam
yeah Auntie Tessa or whatever is Sister
there yeah mad mad yeah wow I forgot
about that yes bro the faces these guys
make yeah bro
scary scary bro the last few episodes
you got to watch surpris you press pause
I was I I think I started to fall asleep
I was watching it till about two oh fair
play couldn't keep my eyes up wow and um
I told you before um carvia I watch in
Japanese so I've been watching it in
Japanese so I I have to concentrate so I
I just charge it it's so Random you
watch it in Japanese I rate it but yeah
yeah yeah it just it it sounds good in
Japanese even though I know it's meant
to be American blah blah blah but I'm so
used to watching anime in Japanese that
I just like [__] it I'm as well but yeah
uh what's her name the the purple ha
yeah um far left left left left the main
she's the she's the main villain in it
um they call her like what do they call
her not no her name is is something B is
that's no no that's not her that's her
boss bro click that isabeth bie is the
uh yeah she's the main main main main
main
one the one with the purple hair is her
Lieutenant okay okay okay okay I can't
remember the purples ones oh so she's
like um I can't remember the the Messiah
the Messiah yeah the vampire Messiah is
um elabe battery and her Lieutenant I
can't remember her name is the one with
the purple hair she is brazy yeah she is
she is she's I thought she was topped on
my bad yeah yeah yeah um God bro it's
all I can't remember the order of events
I don't want to say anything but Jesus
Christ yeah there's stuff I need to
watch I'm going to finish it today yeah
that they leave you on a [__]
Cliffhanger as well it's a [__] tease at
the end oh God it needs it leaves you at
a point where you're like season two has
to drop Tomorrow there's no way you can
make me wait a year for this it's
impossible damn yeah juicy I would I
would highly recommend everyone everyone
everyone this is the recommendation of
the week even though you said it on
patreon last week highly recommend watch
um Castlevania or not not castania
nocturn Netflix ASAP oh bro and I was
I'm going to throw this one out there as
well I know mentioned on patreon before
gen V oh yeah I saw the trailer the
other day I'm going to watch it gen v
may it's early doors it may be on part
if not better than the boys really it's
[__] decent damn bro from the jump
it's actually very decent bro I've said
it before the main character I can't
remember her name anymore um Marie
Monroe whatever yeah baddy say less say
less oh gen V bro is only like four
episodes out yeah ra yeah J in Clair
mainting love of my life say less um but
yeah fam it's decent it's very very very
very decent I'll give that watch as well
say less oh I'm enjoying it I love good
shows man right gang right from here I'm
going to take us in a random twist I've
never done this before okay
and I I don't know who the dude is so
apologies but someone dm' me a few weeks
ago yeah and they were like there's this
um
subreddit where it's just like horror
stories but like real life horror
stories you should do as a segment of
the show to this day I've never taken
anyone's recommendation of a segment for
the show cuz
99.999% of the time is [__] sorry
guys general public I'm sorry sometimes
your recommendations most of the time
recommend are [__] this one was
juicy so I had time I don't know why I
had time that day I had time that day I
went to subreddit read like a I haven't
even read this one but I read like the
preface type of thing kind of preface
like what had the most up votes and all
this kind of thing so I could be like
all right bet let me ask you for and I
thought I'm just going to read it I'm
just going to read it and see how we
feel about it cool
right so I've had this tab open for
literally like two weeks now Okay cool
so um let's see how it goes all right
it's intriguing it is this is intriguing
this could be a new little segment in
okay so right so the title of
this is I was a
captive um oh my God yeah oh my god I
didn't even read it properly the first
time I read it I was a captive God for
almost a decade captive what does that
mean we're going to find out almost a
decade for almost a decade I was a
captive
God that kind of that's that's so that's
either he was like the top da of
capturing
people yeah or I don't know what the
second one could be he was a yeah I've
read little bits I think it means he was
perceived to be a God and was held
captive because of it okay okay yeah so
it's one of the other it's one of the
other and it's long so you man pay
attention grab a drink and pay
attention
right right right you'll have to bear
with me while I tell you my story H so
much of it is written from hazy
Recollections of someone who was in
captivity God don't
misunderstand I wasn't abused in the
traditional sense I was well kept oh I
was well-kept I was well fed and I
really wanted um for nothing except my
freedom juicy opening it is Juicy
opening it is it all started one day
when I visited a new
therapist Dr mallister B the name f
baited the name straight off the Jump
wow wow Dr mallister had been
recommended by a friend of mine he said
that he was very good and that he had
helped him get through a lot of the
issues he had with his mother
mhm and discover some things about his
sexuality mhm he put you under and put
you you in touch with your real
self and that was how he overcame a lot
of your issues it all sounded great to
me I'd been having trouble sleeping and
was looking for some way to get to sleep
and needed to function my insomnia would
sometimes last for days and it was
starting to affect my life so I made an
appointment and two weeks later I was
laying on his couch listening to Dr
mallister countdown from 10 as he put me
in a suggestive
trance them things are scary boy fam
suggestive put me in a suggestive trance
n that just sounds like throat yep it
sounds like I'm giving
throat what you mean I'm under a
suggestive TR Jesus throat you know
right it was very sudden like blinking
but everything changed after that trance
when I came out just as suddenly Dr
mallister looked strange and I asked him
if something had
happened strange may not be descriptive
enough he looked
somehow en raptured
enlightened utterly
[Music]
worshipful Dr mallister you you spoke to
me about things that you couldn't
possibly have known you talked to me
about my childhood you helped me get
over the death of my mother
you helped me more in this hourong
session than I have ever helped
anyone
whoa I wasn't sure what he was talking
about but when he gripped my hand his
eyes Shone with the light of a zalot I
don't know what Zealot
is I actually don't know what Zealot is
bro Google it that for me yeah let's
Google Zealot I have a I think I know
what it
means Zella a person who is fanatical
and uncompromising in pursuit of their
religious political or other ideals yeah
yeah okay Dr mallister again I need more
please let me put you back under so I
can discover more oh wow
fam I pulled away from him and took a
huge step back fact what the hell was he
talking about I'd come here for help but
suddenly he wanted me to help him I had
to get out of here I had to leave now
Fam I'm in the room I'm in the room I'm
in the room you man don't get it I had
to get out of here I had to leave now
mallister tried to stop me but I was out
the door before he could say much more
than stop oh God I didn't sleep well
that night either and it became a real
problem sometimes I would lay in my bed
and swear I heard
Whispers but I put it off as auditory
hallucinations I hadn't slept well for
the past 3 weeks and I knew it was
starting to catch up to me mhm when I
would force myself out of the house for
work or to run errands I could swear I
felt someone watching
meam fam what's more I could swear I'd
catch glimpses of someone out the corner
of my eye but they would always be gone
when I turned to look at them it never
happened in my house always when I was
out and about and the paranoia on top of
the sleep deprivation was slowly eroding
my sanity
M so when I heard someone open a window
in my living room one night I rolled
over and just thought it was me having a
paranoid
hallucination turns out it hadn't been
hallucinations when I heard someone open
my bedroom door I rolled over and found
Dr mallister standing there watching me
no no he looked like he hadn't he oh my
God he looked like he hadn't been
sleeping well either m and his eyes
looked crazed and we stood
looked and we stood looking at each
other I wasn't sure if he was real or
not yeah but when he lunged at me I
curled into a ball and cried out for him
to stop lunged at me woo he didn't
attack me though he didn't hurt me at
all though I now wish he had killed me
right
there oh my God I just remember the
title was captive for 10 years brother
oh my God he didn't hurt me
but I wish he had killed me right there
instead he just instead he just slipped
a needle into my arm and as I watched
his son push down on the plunger I felt
waves of warm and inviting sleep roll
through me Jesus Christ brother Jesus
Christ I woke up in a finished basement
the lights turned down low strapped to a
chair as Dr mallister made sure my
bindings were comfortable I struggled my
limbs heavy and uncoordinated but he
held up a fresh needle and told me if I
didn't calm down he's going to put me
out
again I made myself as still as I could
not sure what to expect there oh sorry
not sure what to expect here this didn't
seem to be a sexual thing I was fully
dressed and the way he was tending to me
almost felt
worshipful Dr mallister I didn't want to
come to this but I can't live without I
can't live without the knowledge you
possess I know you don't believe what
I'm saying but you while you were
unconscious you told me things that uh
may very well change my life you spoke
to me of things that open my eyes ideas
I had never conceived of and the longer
I went without hearing your voice again
the more I felt my new found Serenity
crumbling wow I'm sorry I'm not usually
like this but I had to possess you to
have your knowledge and to understand
your words I can promise you that while
you remain with me you will want for
nothing you are to me as a captured God
that I wish to understand we talked a
lot that night though I mostly yelled at
him to let me go facts but in the end he
just injected me with something to knock
me out and I drift I drifted off into
peaceful unconsciousness Jesus Christ
and that was how I became Dr m Al's
captive God how much more have we
got we've got a lot more I might pause
this and bring it in next week okay yeah
yeah yeah stay tuned very good idea yeah
wow when I say I was there yeah I was
locked in bro when you
said um Dr mallister and what was it a
guy the the bre are just staring at each
other and he lunged at him no
scary you man don't understand
real scary all right cool we're going to
leave it there that's how I became Dr
McAllister's captive God sick this is
from a subre a subre called No Sleep
okay yeah okay yeah okay all right okay
yeah yeah this might this might be a
little new sey say gas all right we'll
pick up the rest all right bet bet we
got Halloween coming up as well oh yeah
Halloween is coming up timeing timeing
all right Pang d right uh trash news
please yeah let's go so professor shows
off confiscated pens that have engraved
with cheat not that have been engraved
with cheat notes by a
student that can't be real how does it
look like that bro that's the tiniest
thing I've seen look
bro what the look at that nah man must
have used the protractor look at the
pens man that's nuts that's crazy if I
CAU is that algebra I'm looking at down
there uh now to the left dead that pen
up a bit yeah this that there I can't
zoom anymore that looks mad bro I don't
know bro yeah if I saw I'm giving him
back the pen like I'm I saw that you
deserve to win the effort is crazy right
facts to
win bro he's willing to do what it takes
whatever this guy's got promise that's
what I'm seeing right sorry carry on
professor shows have confiscated pens
that have been engraved with cheat notes
by a student who studying criminal law
shock Professor professors admitted that
they couldn't help but admire the extent
he went to smuggle cheat notes into the
class according to one of the accused
friends he accomplished this by
replacing the graphite lead of a
mechanical pencil with a needle it made
it super easy for him to write on the
pen damn well played I'm hats off in it
unfortunately for the student he was
caught by an eagle-eyed Professor who
seized his one-of-a-kind set of cheat
notes however his efforts did not go
unnoticed as online users congratulated
his creativity facts yeah bro I would I
I would let him pass I would let us do
it I have to let him do his thing
because these are the people is studying
criminal law these are the people that
are willing to go the extra mile facts
facts clearly you need a man like me in
this job yeah facts you need me in this
role yeah it's just like a little bit of
evil here to save a lot of evil out
there yeah yeah come on man SL man close
one eye yeah close one eye bro what are
we
doing I rate it man I I've never I've I
[__] hate exams I've never performed
well in exams and like it's not the
reason I don't write exams as well is
because it's it's not about what you
know it's about what you remember all
you have to do is remember [__] and then
every exam we've ever done I've just
forgot it as soon as we walked out that
room even if i' passed exam forgot
everything so no qu for me for real yeah
it doesn't make sense that's just the
way to do exams like you said me it's
all memory is like you can't judge
knowledge based on an exam yeah it's
[__] man what if they got anxiety
walk in there forget everything then
what bro it's long then what it's just
long it is long they don't care about
that I hate exam so
much what I also hated as well and there
were certain type of certain types of
exams where
um obviously there's a time let's say
the exam is 2 hours for example there
are some occasions where once we start
no one leaves until the two hours is
done also some exams where once you're
done you can hand in your paper and dip
and then once you start seeing one
person two people people there 10 people
you're like you're looking around
there's like there's like five people
left bro am I stupid someone's going to
put the dance hat on my head any second
any second bro and you can't be the last
one to hand him because you know you're
still failing but what have you been
doing all this time BR I remember when I
think it was just me and
REM was it just me and you that had to
repeat computer
science was that was it me and you I
don't remember what computer size is bro
it was a
oneoff Flippin exam that it was random
it had nothing to even do of our course
we just went into an IT room one day and
flipping did this random uh test I can't
remember what it was called for the life
doesn't ring a bell at all bro I'm Li
bro someone failed with me I know I
failed someone failed I think it was you
and we had to go back to C in summer and
oh in it definitely wasn't me it wasn't
you in summer probably me we had we see
an exam yeah my parents wouldn't let
that down yeah bro and it was the day
before we were going on Holiday May
Miami yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember that it was the day before
Miami and if we if we would have failed
this we would have been [__] because
the next retake was while we were in
Miami yeah I remember that it was me we
had it was me it was me it was there was
a few of us on that on that retake not
from our group but from our class there
was a few heads in there I remember
there was a few people I spting be
people yeah good summer yeah
few there was a few people in there um
because I remember I failed that one
miserably cuz I didn't even know the
thing had started well and and when when
we first did when we did the first exam
yeah I didn't even know the thing had
started properly what remember is the
the lecture or whatever said something
and then everyone's clicking away and I
was just like minding my business and I
didn't realize it started and the test
itself I thought it was like one of them
90minut test 2our tests it was literally
like 35 minutes or something ridiculous
okay and then I I answered like three
questions and there were like 5 minutes
left I was like oh my God oh my God oh
my God I panicked I
panicked oh God they scared the life out
of me oh my God I can see it now your
eyes would have widened yeah I can't
remember what they called it cuz I think
a lot of people did I think a lot of
people in knew he had to do it cuz it
wasn't directly related to our thing it
was called it wasn't computer science it
was some kind of data analysis or
something like that I can't remember H
to me bro I'm not going to lie to I
remember it how how you're describing I
remember it now especially being the day
before we flew out to Miami stressed but
um yeah what it's called what it was
about so you had to BP to kov to do the
exam and then go fly to London to fly to
Miami the day before soon I was uh Bob
to C do the exam go home fly to he go to
he the next day damn yeah yeah I don't
remember that at all cuz I think I was
I'm pretty sure I was in London the day
before Miami now you definitely yeah it
was definitely two of I think it was
me damn I was happy it wasn't just me
cuz I I promise you I wasn't going back
to C by myself yeah you wouldn't have
done it I would I literally would I
would have I would have charged the
whole
degree because I'm not going back to C
to my by myself to do an exam and I'm
not repeating this year by myself either
to stay another year after you might
have gone never I would have chared a
whole
degree so thank God you failed out with
me thank God you did that's jokes um
okay you got dilemma for us I do is my
hubby gay oh God and the title is [__]
or gay question mark oh I'm 30 female
engaged to a 44
male when he um when we had first
started to date sexual desires were
nothing sexual desires were nothing were
nothing tab oh wait what sexual desires
were nothing
taboo yeah that me yeah sex with desires
were nothing taboo as I'm a stripper and
he was a proclaimed dominant oh that's
well here we are 2 years later he
proposed after 6 months oh that's a
sorry a screaming midlife crisis he's 44
years old and he proposed to a stripp
after six months months ick that's what
she wrote ick yeah oh ick okay but she
agreed to marry him yeah I accepted
because shut up then I accepted because
he was someone I would marry but didn't
mean right away anyway the most dominant
he has ever been in the bedroom with
with me um is a few latex outfits worn
for his pleasure now I on the other hand
have had plenty sex toys or have plenty
sex toys Etc that would make our TI much
more enjoyable for me they don't get
used cut to the chase here are the
things um that have been made me qu the
here are the things that have made me
question if this man only likes women
one I'm his third
wife two he knows and is friends with
three openly gay men three his friends
come over only whilst I'm at work in
bracket's conflicting schedules question
mark number four I found not one but
three G masks in in his sex bag along
with [__] cages oh Jesus and other what
I see as male toys none of which um have
ever been played with us together five
we only do quickies and doggy style if
it's in missionary he's closing his eyes
who do you picture
oh yeah number six the fact that we're
on number six is concerning number six
when I asked if he he and a certain
friend are sexual together he said oh my
God why don't you ask him
then
that sounded so jokes oh my God why
didn't you ask him then why don't you
ask him then that's giv Shy Boy Jo oh my
God just ask him just ask him God don't
bother me with this right last and she
says the masks are what truly turned me
off because they seem very predatory to
me like serial killer type [__] trying
to hide DNA and who you really are
thoughts I mean when it said gay or [__]
I was thinking that's screaming Kink
shaming because those are two completely
different
Jaws but after hearing what I said are
you and Donnie sexual together and he
said oh my God don't go and ask
him you're gay yeah or you just not
necessarily gay but you like guys yeah
you like guys there's no way I can say
random a you ever like do you ever like
do a thing and you're like oh my God
Shar ask REM why you asking me ask
REM you're a b boy facts first of all
and rem's living because you're going to
him was like if you had told me to ask
you random I asked you had if you man
bang and he said oh my God ask
REM [__] nah you get plugged in that
situation you get plugged and you're shy
as [__] yeah yeah I'm I'm a bot boy in
that yeah you're a bot boy in that
situation facts but it's number four
that spun me I found not one but three
[__] masks in a sex bag with cck cages
and she's never seen that those that's
never seen the light day that's never
seen the light of day with me and
her that's the boys only come around
when I'm at work yeah I mean she did say
she's a stripper to be fair yeah but
yeah true she's out in the evenings
she's out in evening but why is why are
they only coming over when she's at work
when she's at work sorry do you know
mean know they're having parties in the
yard sauce and they're having parties is
getting sucked in the yard damn that's
yeah it's a lot that really really is a
lot a lot well he's 100% a [__] he but
then I'm hoping she's like locked off
the engagement last marriage I'm hoping
but she's not said so she hasn't said so
and she doesn't sound she said yes she
said yes she said it's a ick and she
still agreed to marry him yeah because
someone she sees the type someone that
she sees marrying in the future but yeah
this is yeah yeah got literally who are
we kidding let's not beat around a bush
he's 15 years older than her facts he
proposed after six months facts and
she's currently working as a stripper
yeah Donny's Kate yeah six fig s yeah
come on man this is the stop being silly
D but that's fine yeah of course but
yeah your husband is um not your husband
yeah he has a proclivity
for dark
meat and that's cool
that's
cool dark me bro his growman throat is
fully fledged oh my escaped yeah a fam
and you just might have to just charge
it and firm it cuz it sounds like what
you're doing anyway facts you're just
trying to you're venting is what you're
doing yeah find finding a three [__]
master that he's never even mentioned
with [__] cages I've never even heard
those two words put together I've never
heard
cages I've never heard those two words
merg together wow ow yeah scary stuff
[__] cages
bro I don't even know what that is bro
I'm trying to even like deep like when
these things are ah REM you save
yourself put it on Incognito bro don't
type in [__] cages on regular Google bro
they'll find us I say that's not it's
not my account that's your account now
you're taking a
piss
end that bro jeez man this is linked to
my home hub
sorry man's got [__] cages in there wow
that's
jokes my Badness
Jesus oh I was going to say I'm pretty
sure it's one of them things oh if you
if you get if you get is a chassity
thing and I feel like it's one of them
things if you get hard it punishes you
bro okay oh it might like stick
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's got sat in
there yeah this is czy stuff this is czy
stuff yeah okay yeah this is long oh
anyway so yeah I was thinking things
like that right she needs to address it
like who's this four facts bro and even
even so let let's let's put let's say
she's gone to work that aside like the
man them in the yard like they're having
fun but it's it's how how they're in the
yard now they're fun like schedule's
clashing clearly they're in the yard now
how there's nothing sexy let's obviously
let's say he he well he he clearly is a
[__] he has got he's got [__] Mark he's
got these cckc but there is nothing sexy
about putting
on the thing that's meant to be like a
taboo do you know what I mean for for
instance this um [__] cage I'm not in
the zone if I'm watching you put this
thing on do you see what I'm saying a
girl no I'm say I'm I'm acting as one of
the gay guys now do you see what I'm
saying oh you're one of the brons that's
come around for fun and you're watching
Donnie put on his cage yeah it's it's
just not sexy to me I think yeah but
it's one of them things right so I'm
assuming hey don't know from experience
just put out there I'm just I'm just
making assumptions okay guys all right I
think this is what how it goes down
right safe space safe space safe space
yeah so I'm assuming
yeah yeah I get all my boys right they
yard now they're in the yard now
everyone's got a
mask yeah everyone's got a mask zipped
up yeah God scary I put on my mask and I
put on my little cage yeah now it's not
about the the me putting on the cage is
not foreplay for you but now that I got
my cage on it's your job to turn me on
okay yeah yeah yeah and if it does turn
me on I'm getting punished yeah so and
you want to see me punished so you're
you're doing all sorts and then that
then turns me on but but if we all got
cages on what's the point me okay
because someone's cheeks are getting
clapped so you can't not everyone can
have cages on true I've probably got a
cage on and assess chaps cheeks are just
spread so yeah okay yeah yeah so you're
doing the most to punish me you know
what I'm saying yeah
yeah say less say less it's czy yeah all
n but that's speculation I don't know
what goes on in that Liv room you
sounded pretty confident he didn't
invite me Fam I'm not going to lie if I
was gay that sounds juice yeah I'm not
going to lie to you man if I was
gay if I was gay that sounds juice do
you not agree though what do you see
what I'm saying you mad you you might
not telling me I can't get hard I'm
going to get
punished I don't think there's a female
equivalent do you see what I'm saying
stop I don't think there's a female
equivalent I could be wrong
I could be wrong
noo I
can't I can't I could be wrong oh my God
oh my
God
jeez bro it sounds like that man have a
way of a
time yeah
bro that's mad bro that's mad there's
equivalent fam there's equivalent what's
the female equivalent
um some examples include a clam jam a
clam jam a [__]
SWAT a box out this what we got clam jam
we got clam jam a [__] SWAT a box out or
a beaver dam jeez Louise huh mhm is this
incognit yes fam Rel I need I need to
see what these look like oh uh okay wait
no it's just merch merch it's just merch
type in a beaver dam what was it that's
what he said be just going to actually
come
[Applause]
up all right never mind yeah but damn
Jesus yeah said sounds juice
bro if you actually deep it I think the
only the female equivalent is one where
you're just like you tell her she can't
nut yeah but that's got nothing to do
with like toys in my opinion oh no no
you're just talking about the toy I'm
talking about the toy equivalent I
thought you talking about the the
stimulation equival no no no no not the
stimulation like the toy equivalent yeah
yeah there's nothing there's nothing
could be done because this is just a
wetting yeah cuz I can't see how I said
it do you're not going to get
punished bro because it's a fact it's
like cause and
effect yeah yeah crazy crazy yeah it's
nuts wow yeah nuts wow indeed wow
indeed Jesus Jesus he's having a whale
of a time that's what I'm saying yeah
nah that's he's having a whale of a time
yes and he's no wonder he's saying she's
saying oh all we do is quickies all we
do is quickies and it's back shots and
it's done because when she's when she's
working yeah hours wow they going a
playing for hours they're playing
hours it's Relentless there's a room
full of them oh my gosh jeez all right
fair play to him fair plays indeed but
yeah um your husband is a [__] and he's
gay and um you just have to either
charge it or move on yeah yeah yeah one
of the too good grief damn right you
said appar you've got a question for us
apparently I have a question for the
gram gram the fandom this is for
everyone this is quick and easy same
question but I'll ask you to answer
individually phone wallet car keys house
keys in your instance you don't drive so
instead of car keys your
laptop keep one lose three for a
week phone wallet house keys car keys
lose three for a week so I want to keep
my phone I I don't have a roof yeah I'm
keeping my house keys right yeah keep my
house
keys phone ballet car
keys I'll just I'll be on my laptop
communication
and my phones I have to take the L I
don't you I need my phone for that I
need my phone fam you need your you need
a roof over your head bro what do you
mean I need what are you doing I need I
box with my phone I can book G I can
book a uber I can book a hotel I book
All Sorts facts I got my passport on I I
can do whatever I
want wow I need
it I need
it yeah I'm keeping my phone I'll keep
my phone yeah yeah yeah yeah you keeping
your house keys I'll keep my house keys
man yeah house keys man see laptop's
gone I know that's the only thing your
phone's gone I love this [__] I'm not
bother about my phone yeah to be fair
you don't you don't reply for hours no
he doesn't I'm the worst with my friend
I get from you only you it doesn't make
sense it does it does make sense because
he doesn't turn on his notifications
it's infuriating let's not get into it
infuriating Lis anyway um so you keep
your house keys so yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah um yeah house keys out of
everything it's got to be man fair play
bro can't not be a home oh phone bro
phone I'll do everything else with the
phone yeah really really yeah car keys I
don't need Uber don't need house keys
don't need stay in a hotel for a week
what else is what did I say house keys
don't need phone don't need wallet
wallet Apple pay Apple pay bro i' never
took my wallet out for years before
anyway so I remember I remember phone
I'm happy the world was caught up with
your
ignorance oh yeah I'm happy time I've
been stopped and said do I have my
wallet with me ever since that those
times you were talking about oh really
yeah in in like events and stuff not
like people say you got your
wallet that was time ago as well it was
time ago yeah but to be fair the amount
every every time anyone sees me where's
Toby that's what I get where's Toby I
bet you hate Toby [__] out my face [__]
out my face I love
Toby but yeah cool cool right thread to
finish thread to finish yeah
bro I'm still laugh the the [__] the
[__] I said it sounds juice
bro the way he depicted it if if I was
if I was
gay it makes sense bro the party makes
sense oh
[Laughter]
God oh my God right um I've had this
thread on my phone for a minute um so
Club CLI the it's a tweet and the thread
is about all the replies okay so the
main tweet is Club closes at 2: a.m. she
didn't get home till four red flag red
flag red flag red flag red flag and all
the responses are from women M so first
one damn can't I help the DJ with his
equipment nah don't yeah don't make
jokes at my expense next I can't help
the hot dog lady sell her hot dogs damn
I can't help the cleaners I can't help
the owners clean their room
damn I can't help my cousin bringing
groceries you guys are
strict it's a
trick all right bet wow damn can I
freestyle in a parking lot for a
[Laughter]
second like chill I got stuck in
traffic ah realistically speaking I'm
probably in the parking lot eating wings
with my eyes closed Oh my days
fair and miss the midnight smack a hopea
loser showdown at Waffle House you know
I love dinner
theater smacka hope
loser I hope that I'll be home as soon
as this dumb [__] gets the [__] out of
my
[Laughter]
way bro women are not for women bro
this this dumb [__] gets the [__] out
of my way and the thing is he wrote that
and it's a caption of a video of a Brea
talking to himself in the mirror he's
gone he's gone
he's fighting himself in the oh Jesus
it's gone last one what do you mean Bae
I'm on my way right now she slumped in
her bushes oh my God yeah that was the
last one it was just a quick thread to
wrap this flag red flag red flag yeah I
I can't find myself in a situation where
I'm waiting up 2 hours CL dance finished
at 2: you're not home till 4: we live 15
minutes away though bro I know cuz my
head will be out the curtains peing
peing I'm living at myself oh God yeah I
would be [__] all that man four two hour
is a long time that's a long time can't
can't help DJ with his equipment ah you
man are
strict that one took my breath away you
man a
strict oh god oh Jesus damn all right
fair play all right this was one of my
most favorite episodes to record in a
while so thank you for that guys day
it's been a good day in general um as
always had over to patreon.com forit and
gigs to get that bonus content on
Thursdays we are now doing ad free
content on there as well come on um but
as always guys love love love gang gang
gang
[Music]
bless